was there any talk at the time
of doing a sequel or did it ever come up
not come up yes oh my god it yes
endlessly came up boy we wanted to
we wanted to make a hard r sequel we
wanted to leave oh
god yeah i mean i think we'd probably
make it tomorrow i mean
yes we tried a lot of different ways to
find um
it was always twos to the studios
who made it which were village roadshow
and um
warner brothers it was always a little
bit of a feathered fish
um it's oddness the thing that you're
talking about which i do think is one of
the most lovely things about the film
the way it is
equally comfortable in a character scene
between keanu and rachel as it is with
demons flying
hurling themselves at a man who's going
to light his fist on fire
and expel them um
is odd right it's not really
action-packed it just has a bunch of
action
this movie isn't exactly a thing it's
kind of a few things which is i think
what's beautiful about it
but those seem to get harder and harder
to make
and even then i think much as we wanted
to and we've talked about it and we've
had ideas
and i would love that one if like he's
wakes up in a cell he has to identify
the
prisoner is that frank's idea remember
and it was jesus
and then he comes up you think it's
in new york i mean you know there were
yeah
yeah we yeah just yeah we talked about
it we would definitely i mean but i i
will say that you know we
we we definitely talked about sequels i
think more than the studio
um because you know the movie did fairly
well and this was also still a time when
people sold dvds so i think it did
decently
um at the time but it wasn't a knockout
success
and it also wasn't really sort of
critically acclaimed by any means at the
time
i mean the kind of cool thing for me
about this movie is just
you know in the 15 years since it
released
every time i do a movie and i go out and
travel the world and do junkets
i am signing constantine deep dvds
more than any other movie that i've done
i mean
over the years different countries and
people
really really love this movie
um and i think that it's it's like found
a sort of a new a new life in a weird
way i mean i even see articles where
people
you know even like rotten tomatoes
posted an article about
you know apologizing to constantine for
you know the rotten tomato account that
it had it just and i think people have
sort of discovered it
recently weirdly um it's always kind of
had
its kind of cult fan base which has been
great but i think people have sort of
discovered it in a new way
so i think we always loved it more than
the studio
loved it
you